Dr fauci  is gone  [Applause]  we just breathe a sigh of relief his  last day of public service was December  30th he recently sat down with the New  York Times for an interview so here he  goes this is after half a century vouchi  prepares for Life After government and I  love that this is the first line of the  article the walls of Dr Anthony s  fauci's home office are adorned with  portraits of him drawn and painted by  some of his many fans the most striking  one is by the singer Joan Baez the two  of them he said have become pretty good  friends over the years tells you  everything you need to know about  Anthony facci the walls of his home  office  are covered in pictures of himself